[Music]
one day in 1965 while driving to
Acapulco for a vacation with his family
colombian journalist gabrielle got Asiya
marquez abruptly turned his car around
asked his wife to take care of the
family's finances for the coming months
and returned home the beginning of a new
book had suddenly come to him many years
later as he faced the firing squad
Colonel Aureliano Buendia was to
remember that distant afternoon when his
father took him to discover ice over the
next 18 months those words would blossom
into one hundred years of solitude a
novel that would go on to bring Latin
American literature to the forefront of
the global imagination earning Garcia
Marcos the 1982 Nobel Prize for
Literature what makes 100 years of
solitude so remarkable the novel
chronicles the fortunes and misfortunes
of the buendia family over seven
generations with its lush detailed
sentences large cast of characters and
tangled narrative 100 years of solitude
is not an easy book to read but it's a
deeply rewarding one with an epic
assortment of intense romances Civil War
political intrigue globe-trotting
adventurers and more characters named
Aureliano than you'd think possible yet
this is no mere historical drama 100
Years of Solitude
is one of the most famous examples of a
literary genre known as magical realism
here supernatural events or abilities
are described in a realistic and
matter-of-fact tone while the real
events of human life and history reveal
themselves to be full of fantastical
absurdity surreal phenomena within the
fictional village of Macondo intertwined
seamlessly with events taking place in
the real country of Colombia the
settlement begins in a mythical state of
isolation but is gradually exposed to
the outside world facing multiple
calamities along the way as years pass
characters grow old and die only to
return as ghosts or to be seemingly
reincarnated in the next generation when
the American Fruit Company comes to town
so does a romantic mechanic who is
always followed by yellow butterflies a
young woman up and floats away
although the novel moves forward through
subsequent generations time moves in an
almost cyclical manner many characters
have similar names and features to their
forebears whose mistakes they often
repeat strange prophecies and visits for
mysterious gypsies give way to the
skirmishes and firing squads of repeated
civil wars an American Fruit Company
opens a plantation near the village and
ends up massacring and thousands of
striking workers mirroring the real-life
banana massacre of 1928 combined with
the novel's magical realism this
produces a sense of history as a
downward spiral the characters seem
powerless to escape
beneath the magic is a story about the
pattern of Colombian and Latin American
history from colonial times onward this
is a history that the author experienced
firsthand Gabrielle Garcia Marquez grew
up in a Colombia torn apart by civil
conflict between its conservative and
liberal political parties he also lived
in an autocratic Mexico and covered the
1958 Venezuelan coup d'etat as a
journalist but perhaps his biggest
influences were his maternal
grandparents
Nikolaus Ricardo marques is a decorated
veteran of the thousand days war whose
accounts of the rebellion against
Colombia's conservative government led
Gabriel Garcia Marquez to a socialist
outlook meanwhile Dona tronky Lina
Aguada notices on the present
superstition became the foundation of
100 Years of Solitude
style their small house in aracataca
where the author spent his childhood
formed the main inspiration for Macondo
with one hundred years of solitude
Gabriel Garcia Marquez found a unique
way to capture the unique history of
Latin America he was able to depict the
strange reality of living in a
post-colonial society forced to relive
the tragedies of the past in spite of
all this fatalism the novel still holds
hope at his Nobel lecture gotta see
America's reflected on Latin America's
long history of civil strife and rampant
in it witty yet he ended the speech by
affirming the possibility of building a
better world
to quote where no one will be able to
decide for others how they die where
love will prove true and Happiness be
possible and where the races condemned
to one hundred years of solitude will
have at last and forever a second chance
on earth are you ready to dive into
Gabriel Garcia Marquez's masterpiece you
can download an audio version of 100
Years of Solitude for free by visiting
audible.com slash ted-ed
every free trial created through that
link help support Ted's nonprofit
mission
[Music]